على قطع عائله كرداشان يشارك نجم هوليوود
سيلفستر ستالون في برنامج للتلفزيون
الواقع مع افراد اسرته
الافلام
مع زوجته وبناته الثلاثه وهم يمارسون
انشطه حياتهم اليوميه يقول ان يوجه رساله
من خلال البرنامج مفاد ان العائلات بكل
مظاهر الثروه التي تمتلكها لديها ايضا نفس
القضايا والرغبات ونفس الاحتياجات بالفعل
هو ايضا علق على مقارنته ببرنامج عائله
كارداشيان رد ستلون بانهم سيظهرون او
يظهرون مسارا مختلفا
راح نشوف راح نشوف لا راح نشوف شو اسمه
راح يطلع البرنامج هذا
ستايل خاص
ابر متت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات